oh hayley hayley
[Music]
she did it again again and again haley
bieber transforms into four iconic
britney spears music video looks for
halloween and kills every single one of
them
i thought it was really brilliant really
fun first up the 24 year old channeled
the pop star and baby one more time
[Music]
she even gave us an inside glimpse into
her glam sesh for the look
then the model played with our hearts in
this skin-tight red jumpsuit from oops i
did it again and oh this one
[Music]
hayley slayed britney's i'm a slave for
you look from the hot pink top to her
hair and down to the walk you betcha
you betcha
she also recreated the gimme more
singer's rolling stone cover rocking
pajamas with a telephone in her hand
cuddled with a teletubby haley captioned
all the looks quote happy halloweekend
the first concert i ever went to was the
queen britney spears and i've been shook
ever since
[Music]
now as far as her hubby justin bieber
for halloween he decided to channel belu
the bear from disney's the jungle book
forget about your worries and your
strides
but justin also made it swaggy by adding
a special touch yep the ice around his
neck very cool guy yeah saturday night
the biebs and his wife who swiped her
brick costumes for a classic black cat
look for the evening stepped out to a
star-studded squid game themed party
with guests including olivia rodrigo
paris hilton sophie turner joe jonas and
rebel wilson we have a good time
together
back in 2016 we spoke to haley about
what it is she loves about spending time
with her man
you know
he's really funny he's just really sweet
he's a good kid he's a good part and
i love him